У цьому парку в Антверпені
ісламісти нерідко вербували молодих бельгійців
до своїх лав в Сирію та Ірак.
Нині деякі з них повертаються додому.
Це непокоїть місцевих жителів.
Колишні бійці "Ісламської держави" намагаються
непомічено реінтегруватися в суспільство.
Депутат міськради Антверпена Хішам Ель-Мзаір
знає декого з них особисто і попросив їх розповісти
DW свої історії.
Утім, ніхто не захотів говорити.
Багато хто повертається із почуттям сорому.
І вони не хочуть це показувати,
розголошувати своє ім’я або виступати на телебаченні,
мовляв, я поїхав туди, бо був дурний, і от повернувся.
Утім, є винятки. Минулого року Лаура Пассоні
неодноразово виступала на телебаченні після
публікації своєї автобіографічної книги
про життя як нареченої бойовика в Сирії.
Вона вирішила втекти, коли її 4-річний син
прийшов до неї і показав, як його навчили
обезголовлювати плюшевого ведмедика.
Нині Лаура Пассоні проводить бесіди в школах,
щоб запобігти радикалізації.
У деяких колишніх бойовиків є інші причини
залишатися в тіні.
І вони найбільше непокоять міського депутата
та мусульманську громаду міста.
Вони не хочуть, щоб ми знали, що вони повернулися.
І якщо чесно, вони зовсім не соромляться.
Вони швидше розчаровані, що "Ісламська держава"
та її халіфат зазнають поразки.
Але ці люди серед нас.
Схоже, що саме так почувається Мішель Делефортрі.
Він також написав книгу та дав численні інтерв’ю,
як ось це для "Євроньюз",  у яких прославляв
так звану "Ісламською державу".
Він шкодує лише про те, що повернувся.
Поговорити з ним ми не змогли, бо чоловік
у в’язниці – і не через підтримку ІД.
Місцева влада шукає підхід до людей,
які повертаються з лав ІД.
Бельгійське місто ВІлворде багато молодих людей залишили,
щоб приєднатися до бойовиків "Ісламської держави".
Мер Ганс Бонте відвідує колишніх бойовиків у в’язниці,
щоб переконатися, що вони розуміють, який у них вибір.
Він застерігає їх, що і після звільнення за ними стежитимуть.
Я сказав їм: коли вас випустять, ви вільна людина,
ви відбули своє покарання, у вас є права
і ми надамо вам усі можливості,
щоб реінтегруватися у правильний спосіб.
Ганс Бонте наводить приклад, як його адміністрація
та міська громада підтримали колишнього бойовика,
який хотів стати законослухняним.
Головне у цій справі – відкритість.
Ми поінформували роботодавця, і той був готовий
дати йому шанс, ознайомившись з пакетом документів,
який ми йому передали. Так само подбали про помешкання.
Це – одна з успішних історій і два роки потому.
Утім, не кожен випадок вдалої реінтеграції заслуговує на довіру.
Пітер ван Остаєн, один з найвідоміших
дослідників бельгійського джихаду, каже,
що в соцмережах голос європейських радикалів потужний які ніколи.
Наскільки потужний їхній вплив?
Боюсь, що ми про це дізнаємося,
коли станеться наступний теракт.
Утім, бельгійська влада більш
оптимістична, ніж ван Остаєн.
Не так давно рівень терористичної загрози офіційно знизили:
ймовірність теракту змінила статус
із "вірогідно" на "маловірогідно".